[Music]
welcome back to the Julian podcast
[Music]
trying to hold him in this little pouch
all day long seeing if I can do it all
day long he's enjoying himself he is
except for I couldn't do while he ate or
while he did his business it's just
pretty jealous right now did you know no
I'm spending time with our other child
not you just honked at you this episode
is brought to you by me undies guys get
everything you need for you and your
loved ones for this holiday season at me
and ease with four different cuts for
men and women all of which come in their
amazing
micro modal fabric three times softer
than cotton get 15% off a pair of the
most comfortable undies when you go to
me undies comm slash annejulien SME UND
IES comm slash annejulien
ordered by 12 16 16th of this month
which it's now December by the way guys
deal with it it is crazy but deal with
it order by the 16th and you will
receive your order before Christmas also
guys wink if you're struggling to find
wine for you and your loved ones and you
go to the store and you don't know what
to do when you're in the wine aisle
you're just like all these bottles I
don't know let wink do all the work for
you ok they send you great wine that you
will like specifically alright there's
no membership fee skip any month cancel
anytime shipping is complimentary go to
TR Y winc com trying to accomplish Jenna
and Julian for $20 off also guys lastly
post mates which is what we used today
to get our wonderful brunch posts mates
as a delivery app for restaurants that
don't have delivery is amazing it's
streamlined it is simple and convenient
right now use code Jenna Dewan when you
download post mates for $100 of free
delivery credits when you try the app
you will not regret it it is an amazing
app can't say enough good things about
it
thank you sponsors thank you sponsors
hi Kermit Julian came up with a really
fun thing to do cuz I laughed the second
day you said yeah I was like we were
trying to come up with an idea and I
just I like a lot of times I'll have
something about head I definitely don't
say it because I'm like this is so dumb
but that time I was just like honestly
what's the worst second I'm gonna say
and you laughed I was like how do you
like this idea well I mean it could suck
it could be completely not good we don't
know yet but like I'm ready for it to be
awesome because I looked up some that
are gonna be awesome oh you have some
good ones I have some good one am I
gonna am I gonna get outplayed yeah
let's just say we did this in two
different styles so I asked Julian how
many do you have you noticed are sitting
there like well describe what it is so I
just had this idea that you get a recipe
and just read the increase just read the
ingredients of the recipe so but not the
steps yeah just the ingredients okay but
so I was like Julian how many do you
have so far and he goes I have 30 no
it's like I have to because I'm going
through and like on Pinterest and
finding them and you know you have to
scroll through this small novel that
they wrote in this beginning I don't
know what can we talk about that why is
every single Pinterest recipe I don't
with a life story before and like I get
that they're trying to you know set
themselves apart or establish you know
there's a style that's how they make a
brand good for them but like I want just
put it at the top and then I'll be more
enticed to be like you know what this
person put it at the top I want to read
their life story now I don't think
that's know wouldn't I'm lying I'm
giving false promises just to get what I
want so I have like handful and Julian
has like 100 but he hasn't read yet but
you haven't read them why would I need
here's a why would I need to read the
recipe if I say I'm searching for pasta
right I search pasta on Pinterest a
picture of pasta pops up I click on it
that's a recipe for pasta so I add it to
my board why didn't you read the
ingredients because it's not like I'm
gonna click on and it's gonna be like
you know I read the recipes because I
wanted it to be something interesting if
I read it out loud to you for you and
our listener
and or viewers to guess but my me
providing interesting content is me
finding interesting recipes that I know
are interesting by searching for the
interesting terms okay so you haven't
read any of the recipes zero absolutely
yeah okay I haven't even gotten past the
picture okay but I promise it'll be good
mm-hmm
and if it's not you can hold me
personally accountable mm-hmm so you
went through Pinterest you know
sometimes when you click on a recipe it
takes you to if you pin it it takes you
to a link that has like 30 or 50 dinners
of some certain style and like you have
to scroll for an hour 250 dinners for
the 4th of November like that yeah are
you saying that I'm gonna fail gonna do
well alright listen do you have so many
why don't you hit me with one why don't
I do the honors I'll do the honors okay
I created a new board for myself
it's called podcast recipes mm-hmm
delicious okay are you ready for this
cuz I got some weird [ __ ] I got some
weird [ __ ] dude karma is demanding to be
part of this podcast alright I'm ready
ingredients okay one cup of small curd
cottage cheese Trader Joe's style okay
1/4 a teaspoon of pepper butcher butcher
ground Oh does that mean pre ground
pepper hello dude who uses pre grab 1/4
a teaspoon of granulated garlic and
finally 1/4 a teaspoon of onion powder
that's all you get just cheese and
spices hey Jenna
good luck oh my god how much cottage
cheese a cup yeah one cup can I also
tell you like a utensil you might use
this might help a small mixing bowl
I don't know spicy cottage cheese like
oh my god y'all want to come over for
the game yeah sure what should we bring
oh nothing we're making spicy cottage
cheese just bring a spoon it's gonna be
a small bowl so get here fast it's gonna
go it's no guesses do you want - oh
you'd be surprised is it like deep-fried
oh you're getting somewhere yeah do you
just like gloop it into a fryer and now
you have like spicy cheese balls
um well all right just tell me what it
is you're close just tell me it's Quito
cheese chips I didn't do it but yeah
okay what is the method in a small bowl
mix cottage cheese with spices heat a
large nonstick frying pan over medium
heat for one to two minutes that's a
long time to be heating it with nothing
gonna scoop 1/2 a teaspoon of cottage
cheese mixture into the pan cook for one
to two minutes once the cheese has
stopped bubbling the surface is dry and
starting to brown use a rubber spatula
to lift the edges from the pan carefully
peel the chip away
from the pan flip and cook an additional
20 to 30 seconds repeat with remaining
batter so you're just making that just
making pancakes but it's cheese I like
cheese when it's like cooked and you
ever just put some cheese in the
microwave and let it melt like this I do
that idea yeah I know I do
delicious no we're making fun of like
cooked cheese as a snack but I've 1000%
on multiple occasions in my life poor
cheese onto a paper plate put in the
microwave and grab the fork afterwards
I'm down really funny well one for one
baby feeling good to start by the way
guys I hope you like our new mic arms
Julie drilled into our table I drove him
to the table so I don't know how long
this tables gonna last now that I got
done with it but for a long time I would
notice any time I would get towards the
edge of the frame there would be a giant
mic arm in my face like right here so we
got these low profile ones so hopefully
you can see our mugs better I'm like I'm
so upset because the things that I
pinned have nothing on what you just did
oh you just buckle up dude no buckle
buckle
are you ready for my first one yeah yeah
yeah twelve ounces of cream cheese no
way it softened what sorry it was just
an overreaction
wait softened like it okay sir like you
leave it out from the fridge and let it
get a little soft like four to three
days and sorry 3/4 of a cup of powdered
sugar a teaspoon of pure vanilla extract
a cup of peanut butter warmed in the
microwave half a cup of chopped Reese's
peanut butter cups 2 cups of Reese's
Pieces and graham crackers
dude peanut butter cheesecake that's a
really educated guess what is it hey
wait one more time read it through 12
ounces of cream cheese softened a
three-quarters of a cup
sugar teaspoon of vanilla extract a cup
of peanut butter warmed in the microwave
half a cup of chopped Reese's peanut
butter cups - 2 cups of Reese's Pieces
and graham crackers yeah my guess would
be it would be peanut butter or Reese's
cheese cake or it would be peanut butter
velvet cupcakes
wait why no yeah well coz red velvet
cupcakes have have cream cheese in the
fit in there but there's nothing here to
make a batter out of there's no flour
desert bagel spread honestly not the
worst guess the picture is really what
did it for me it's a Reese's peanut
butter ball so it's a ball like you know
when you put a cheese ball so it's a
dessert cheese ball it's a dessert
cheese ball and butter the cream cheese
and the chopped Reese's peanut butter
cups and all of the Reese's Pieces are
smushed on top of it and then you dip
your graham cracker into it or you dip
the knife and spread it on their graham
cracker exactly that's funny if I get
dessert cheese ball mm-hmm that's funny
it's also like maybe stop cooking for it
today maybe hang up the old apron eat
some Reese's Pieces and called an
afternoon beads yeah I I came across a
surprising amount of cheeseball recipes
wasn't looking through Pinterest
they love their cheese balls I love the
cheese and I when I search the best what
I search anything
yeah it Pinterest is incredible actually
when I searched cheese balls I was
expecting to find like the puffs you
know mm-hmm but that's not what I found
okay okay you ready he's just so hot all
the time he's hot and nasty dude I just
already got a selfie what in the rest
yeah I'm just trying to get down to oh
man we should've just taken screens yeah
yeah this is this is unprepared of me Oh
got a picture of their kitchen
okay this is anemic okay I'm just you're
getting Pinterest yeah I just got
interested I'm moving on to the next one
I can't I can't deal with that right now
okay
you ready mm-hmm okay cuz I'm ready
one can of refrigerated buttermilk
biscuits cuz it said biscuits whatever
three tablespoons of unsalted butter
melted two tablespoons of grated
Parmesan cheese fresh sure can't hey hey
not for you parmesan okay so yep so far
we have biscuits butter and cheese half
a teaspoon of each but also all of my
recipes have no calories and 1/2
teaspoon of each garlic powder dried
oregano dried parsley that's like some
pinch of salt that's all you get okay in
a preheat oven
mmm for 400 degrees so I'm guessing that
you probably picked this recipe because
the biscuits were combined with those
ingredients like butter and salt and
spices and cheese in some sort of really
good looking fashion mmm like a wreath
or like a cake or a swan yeah a swan you
might need to just rein it in a little
bit I don't think I picked the garlic
Swan but I appreciate that you think I
would biscuits on a garlic biscuits one
is that your final answer
garlic biscuits one absolutely incorrect
but you're close in a sense that there's
garlic in both of what you guessed at my
original recipe and that's the only
reason it's my own Pinterest recipe
because you pinned it to your board I'm
the CEO of Pinterest it's garlic knots
there's literally just garlic knots I
weigh over thoughts yeah I think that is
an understatement
overthink everything so I come out hot
right out of the gate with keto chips
and so then afterwards that's part of
the strategy is now you're just
overthinking everything you're
second-guessing every intuition all
right give me another one I only have
like six oh yeah dude I'll rattle off
I'll rattle off a few right here right
here and now that was from the comfort
of cooking not that I need to shout out
any of these out I thought it was your
recipe Julian yeah I founded the comfort
of cooking okay here we go ingredients 2
pounds of medium cheddar cheese mmm one
and a half cups of Nacho Cheese Doritos
one in that I'm not done I'm not done
one and a half cups of spicy nacho
cheese Doritos Doritos for eggs oh one
and a half cups of flour half a teaspoon
of black pepper teaspoon and a half of
garlic powder and a quart a quart of
vegetable oil you're making deep fried
Dorito balls and cheese and then fried
cheese stuff torito's damn you just
nailed that dude that was good that was
good if you tell me that you have a
quart of oil what do you think you're
gonna do with it Julian its roll
pinchers take down your pants start
massaging yourself okay so this I have
another one I'm gonna do right okay
a big pot mmm one cup of short grain
rice white rice preferably that's your
own judgment being inserted into this
recipe you know me too well it actually
says white rice vegetable stock but you
can also use chicken stock or no stock a
few if you prefer it more bland mmm
which I don't know why they would
include that sentence cuz who goes
to a Pinterest meal thinking I'd prefer
this a little more glam well like for
kids if you're cooking it for little
kids or something maybe okay
in the last recipe or the last
ingredient you ready
yeah water its water I'm not making rice
that's okay so that's like the base
version of this they also add about like
things to make it more tasty but you
don't have to add them I'm gonna give
you a couple of suggestions of
ingredients and spice it up okay
scallions created ginger salt or soy
sauce not both white pepper black pepper
works fine I don't know why they wrote
white chili oil or vegetables with a
recipe stock rice and water in a pot
you're making rice not think about the
ratio here okay I wanted to have one and
a half cups of rice oh it doesn't
sandwich water it just as well are you
ready no you in here I'm making gruel
[Music]
[Music]
what do they say glasses Alba can't see
because I need my glasses to see you
yeah oh that's the base recipe of gruel
yeah the pot I think you just let it get
mushy
there's no flair to it this is basic
it's a basic recipe that's why they
serve it like gruel like they [ __ ] up
and they were like okay I was making
rice but now I guess I'll eat it but
they put too much water and let it cook
for too long or just they were trying to
make rice and then they forgot that they
had to go on vacation for three days and
then they came back and it was gruel so
there you have it
it's a gruel recipe off Pinterest that
was probably the least Pinterest thing
on the entire website of Pinterest look
at how its this is how its formatted
it's the worst
who's that it's hurt anyway
what do you got next I can go again I
got more in the tank I'm ready to ready
to fly okay three and a quarter pounds
of lean ground beef okay yeah twelve
cups of apples peeled cored and diced
six cups of raisins one cup of brandy
tablespoon of ground cinnamon a
tablespoon of ground allspice a
tablespoon of ground nutmeg three and a
half cups of white sugar that's it one
more time reading through one more time
three and a quarter pounds of lean
ground beef that's the part I don't get
12 cups of apples peeled cored and diced
6 cups of raisins 1 cup of brandy 1
tablespoon of ground cinnamon 1
tablespoon of ground allspice 1
tablespoon of ground nutmeg 3 and a half
cups of white sugar if you're from
somewhere cold that but you know what
this is is it like a stew why is there
ground beef and then a bunch of sweet
things apples mm-hmm I literally have no
idea I don't even know what to guess
like I don't know what name to say
apples is it like a can I get a hint is
it like a holiday thing is it like a
festive like a winter thing it's a
winter but it's not like holiday
yeah like Bialik beef stew beef cider
what is it
it's the mincemeat pie filling mincemeat
pie filling hmm
so that's what I think like British
people I don't have any meat in there
mincemeat pie mm-hmm but this is the
real mincemeat with meat meat mincemeat
pie meat
what's with the apples why would someone
want apples in a in a pie with meat it's
fun it was like one of my stepmoms
favorite pies and she's so nice all the
sweet and savory kind of thing yeah I'm
sorry I sucked at that one did all right
you ready for my next one yeah one egg
white 1/4 a cup of all-purpose flour
unbleached one-eighth teaspoon vanilla
extract 1/4 a cup Oh an ad popped up 1/4
a cup of white sugar and a pinch of salt
and egg Carmy no we're playing a game
and you were just up here but you got
too hot with your little hot body stop
it an egg white flour vanilla sugar salt
pretty much how much flour I think it
said a cup Wow 1/4 cup only 1/4 cup and
1 egg white how you making a pancake I'm
not making a pancake are you making an
egg white cookie no well it's not called
that but yeah can't say no so you're
gonna take the egg white and you're
gonna mix it with the flour sugar salt
vanilla you may be in a crepe no that
was a good guest there's so there's
literally so many guesses with this set
of ingredients can I read you some of
the met like the method to give you a
hint sure you need strips of paper okay
you know what what you need strips of
paper for what part of the recipe
just tell me where I'll tell you I lose
are you making an edible paper mache no
why would you need strips of paper for
the recipe give me another hint
stop it no lay down help me
the paper is not only used for like a
tool in the recipe process it becomes
ingrained in the final product so you're
eating paper
you're not eating paper No are you
eating it off the paper no just tell me
what it is it's a fortune cookie Julie
you put a strip of paper inside the
fortune cookie you don't eat the paper
but it's in there
you're a thousand percent right I know
give me another one all right I don't
even know if you know what this is but I
used to eat this a lot growing up and I
just actually found out upon looking it
up on Pinterest that it's like pretty
much vegan like you can really easily
make this vegan and it's gluten free as
well but I had this growing up I think
it's it I think it's like a
traditionally a Jewish thing it's a
dessert two cups of honey one teaspoon
of vanilla extract one and a half cups
of pistachios toasted and unsalted or
you could use almonds but pistachios are
preferred and two cups of tahini
pistachio hummus no hummus that is
probably the most gross name I've ever
heard this Thomas
that sounds like piss and stomach and
ass in one word you don't like that word
not no it's not I honestly guarantee
someone has already guessed what I'm
describing I know a Jewish dessert with
pistachio it's traditionally Jewish I'm
not positive I don't know I used to eat
like a lot of the high
holidays for that stuff at my Jewish
friends houses and I've never had a
pistachio dessert so I don't know hmm
what is it are you sure you want me you
know other yummy and pistachios I have
no idea
it's either piss dumbest or it's
something I halva never even heard of
Holland oh I had a feeling you might not
notice wait so the only thing you would
sell out is the honey right yeah you
could just want vegan honey and then
you'd be good to go or even like agave
or maybe something like that halva is
I'll show you a picture it's um this is
what it looks like should be called
pistol actually that's kind of a weird
looking a picture but it's like it's
hard and it's like very flaky yeah and
you cut a piece of it and you get to you
just like kind of eat it yeah it's an
it's sweet but it has like a dry
sweetness to it it's something like
really good halva is can be like doesn't
get that hard or is it it's so it's not
like hard but it's like a block and then
you it's sort of like if you can imagine
maybe like a cheese block yeah and then
but it's very flaky so if you'd cut a
piece off of like sheds like in thin
strips like it you know it doesn't hold
together very well yeah
I love we should make that dude it's
that is like that will hit me right in
the childhood okay I'm down that sounds
really good all right Julian Julian
Julian a cup of whole milk whole milk
hmm six slices of white bread 2 pounds
of ground beef one heaping cup of
freshly grated Parmesan cheese 1/4
teaspoon of seasoned salt 3/4 teaspoons
of regular salt freshly ground black
pepper 1/3 a cup of minced flat leaf
parsley four whole eggs beaten 10 slices
of thin regular bacon one-and-a-half
cups of ketchup 1/3 a cup of brown sugar
one teaspoon of dry mustard and two
Basco to taste sloppy joe
guess what the [ __ ] that is so many
things for two slices of bread
no there's six slices of white bread oh
I think there was two so there's six
slices of bread there's ground beef
there's all sorts of seasoning there's
ketchup did you say tomato anything any
other ketchup did you say cheese
anywhere no no cheese
but there is whole milk oh yeah that's
the weird part is it like beef french
toast no beef toast beef bread it is
kind of like beef bread I don't know oh
oh beef wellington
it's not a beef well you don't use white
bread for a beef wellington
I don't think Gordon Ramsay uses white
bread and Gordon Gordon says it around
his courtyard
we know you use white bread for your
Wellington's we know you do well it's
from hi I'm REE Drummond the Pioneer
Woman well I don't even and it is her
exquisite don't bacon meatloaf
oh so how can you read how do you make
that I'm just sure
well meatloaf the ingredients are
similar instead of the white bread
there's bread crumbs but it's similar to
how you'd make a meatball okay so the
the fact that yeah the bread I would
have guessed bread crumb I would have I
would have guessed meatballs if you said
bread crumbs and not bread but the fact
that she uses whole bread was throwing
me off because I thought it was like an
end up being like a sandwich you pour
milk over the bread slices and allow it
to soak in for several minutes place the
ground beef milk-soaked bread Parmesan
seasoned salt salt black pepper and
parsley in a large mixing bowl pour in
beaten eggs with clean hands mixed with
dirty-ass here like why would she write
with clean hands go out and do something
real nasty with yourself mix the
ingredients until well combined
with clean hands form the mixture into a
loaf shape in a broiler pan which will
allow the fat to drain line in the
bottom of the pan with foil to avoid a
big mess
hehe lay bacon slices over the top
tucking them underneath the meatloaf and
then to make the sauce you add ketchup
brown sugar mustard and hot sauce in a
mixing bowl I actually when I was a kid
my mom would make meatloaf and I did
really like it mine
yeah yeah I literally never grew up
having me loved my reaction to that
being like you who is not that like any
less gross it's just like I didn't
expect that to be a meatloaf recipe but
the best part about this game is that
you can make anything that we're
describing right now like it's festive
and if you don't have the ingredients
you know you can get them off of post
mates
you can post mates the ingredients to
your house right now or wherever you are
your workplace your friend's apartment
your girlfriend's apartment maybe not a
bus bench but somewhere pretty close to
that you could get post mates you can
give rice and water you could get rice
it's just right so you can make yourself
some gruel if you guys are hungry right
now and you're craving something yummy
and not also not really that healthy
gruel is the way to go and you can get
you can achieve a really great basic
paper taste in gruel right now with post
mates or anything delicious aside from
the rule right now guys post mates is
offering you $100 towards your delivery
credits in the first seven days when you
use post mates and use code Jenna
Julianne post mates is a great app you
log on sometimes if you don't feel like
cooking or you just you know you saw a
restaurant on the way home and you're
like I'm in my socks in my me Andes and
I'm drinking a glass of wink wine I'm
like sponsor overload right and you just
don't want to go out postmates so
they'll cover you so you select off the
menu or off of the list of items they
have in the store or whatever or if they
don't have it you can enter a custom
item which is what we do a lot of times
especially if you have like a lot of
variations to your order and the post
mate will go and pick it up from the
restaurant and deliver it to your house
very simple and it's it's so hassle-free
so right now guys download postmates use
code Jenna Julian in the app and they're
giving you $100 a free delivery credit
in your first seven days I
no you guys won't be disappointed it's
such a great app also guys me Andy's the
most comfortable soft underwear you can
buy with money it's like if you haven't
felt me in these it is truly truly a new
experience when it comes to the fabric
softness it doesn't make sense but it is
there and every every day when I wake up
my me and these are there for me and
they could be there for you too they
have amazing amazing onesies Oh
can't even get enough of the onesies
they have bra let's they have lounge
pants they have underwear they have
socks all with the super super soft
micro modal fabric and right now they
have an offer for you first time
purchasers do you guys get 15% off and
free shipping when you purchase any me
undies using our URL Mandy's comm slash
Jenna Julian and again if you're trying
to get this for a Christmas present
which I think Mandy's is such a festive
and wonderful Christmas present for your
loved ones because they're not going to
not wear it just make sure you order by
the 16th to get the order delivered by
Christmas so you can be the king of
Christmas or the queen of Christmas or
the me Andes Santa that's me undies comm
slash Jenna Julie and also guys wink
what a great service right you don't
know exactly what wine to pick but you
know the type of wine you enjoy wink
helps you basically what wink is it
spelled winc you go on to their website
and they give you a flavor profile test
where they get exactly what kind of
palate you like when it comes to wine
but also just like flavors in general
and they use that information to
formulate a lineup of lines that you
would like and then they send you the
wines like it's amazing you don't have
to do any of the work they do it all for
you they have wine experts that that
help curate exactly to your specific
liking of what wines to send you and you
can just discover all sorts of new great
wines starting today so go to try wink
that's ery winc comm slash Jenna and
Julianne and you get $20 off your first
shipment and they will cover the
shipping fees so check it out don't
stand in that wine aisle anymore not
understanding what wine is what just try
wink all right links down below thank
you sponsors
all right well would it be okay would it
be okay if I gave you a different
version of like a different flavor of
gruel or we don't know doing no more
gruel okay and also if I give you a
really weird recipe and you think I'm
lying I'll show you I'll show you the
fact that it's a real six medium bananas
fourth a cup of lemon juice thin six
thin slices of boiled ham okay you know
three tablespoons of prepared mustard
two envelopes of hollandaise sauce mix
what and 1/4 a cup of light cream is it
like banana Eggs Benedict
very close bananas benedict mmm bananas
hollandaise that's disgusting
Oh No
oh no the picture is them the bananas
laid out on a tray all in a row and then
there's ham covering each one and the
whole thing is just covered in holidays
this hollandaise oh this is a dream come
true to at least one person out there
who just cannot get enough of bananas
with everything but also loves their
eggs many and they're like oh my god I
never liked any my fetish has been
completely achieved with this recipe
someone out there is feeling that and
honestly [ __ ] go live your life dude
get on with your bad self and eat those
bananas with hollandaise because I
imagine it's gonna be an experience I
don't like hollandaise sauce I never did
Oh hollandaise is great I don't like any
like thick mayo II sauce you know I love
Meili sauce I never eat mayo growing up
I do like don't really like it I see
Mayo aioli Oh chicken salad with the
Mayo
oh I love me
I love Mayo II sauces hollandaise sauce
you can really easily make that a taste
of it and I'm like that's enough when I
made you the the vegan eggs Benny I mean
it's okay no that sauce was fine because
it's not mayo basis it's not like you
took vegan mayo and like made it you
know you have it's it's prepared but
like hollandaise is not just FAO sauce
it's actually like I've looked up a lot
of recipes and also if you want to find
a really great hollandaise recipe Kenji
Lopez alt makes really really good
recipe videos are good because it was
like tangy and not thick and gross
there's a like it's a big process to
make good hone is you have to like it's
it's all about the timing and how much
you're yeah if you're making it with
eggs well if you're making it with
realize yeah but then also like I made
it
obviously vegan so it's still a
difficult recipe like it still requires
a lot of finesse but that is disgusting
Julie and it's bananas covered in ham
covered in hollandaise sauce
hey disgusting all I gotta say is don't
knock it till you try it so if you're
never gonna try it you're never gonna
knock it
am I right men I do another one I wonder
another go for it okay here's what
you'll need three five and a half inch
rectangle cookies with rounded edges you
already need cookies to start rectangle
cookies that's one of the English a
homescreen paper template what what is
that a homescreen paper template wax
paper tape okay flood consistency royal
icing tipless piping bags hmm
decorating tips white pearl dust gold
pearl dust blush gold pearl dust silver
pearl dust edible ink markers gray
edible markers brushes colored extract
paint palette or small dishes and add a
edible wafer paper you're making a
cookie iPhone
yes I'm making an iphone cookie
literally oh my god
it looks so bad so bad and it's not
edible a lot of those ingredients like
tape Wow go through the trouble of
having edible markers and then tape no
you're not gonna eat the tape you
probably use the tape for something I
don't know man they look kind of wild on
here I got another one let me go let me
go do me me okay ready okay okay here we
go
one cup of 100% juice juice okay
100% cut yeah it comes to come get y'all
wait they should make a juice brand come
get y'all come get y'all juice and then
it's a picture of the kids smashing into
the two tablespoons of honey mm-hmm
fourth a teaspoon of sea salt they use
Redmond six cups of cold water that's
the salt they use Redmond I don't know
okay okay so water honey salt juice 100%
juice what is that noise is that the
dryer that's outside it's a construction
what is that I don't know it sounds like
someone's outside like moving stuff okay
what you want me to look outside all
right
I'll sit here and think water honey salt
and juice are you making like a popsicle
I'm not making a popsicle yeah it's like
our neighbors moving stuff around I
think
I'm not making a popsicle this is a good
recipe to have in the summer or whenever
you need to drink something tea
no but close hot juice with honey it's
not hot cold juice with honey no it's
not a popsicle it's not a popsicle
okay homemade Gatorade those are just
some one took the labels off of plastic
Gatorade bottles and filled it with
their shitty Pinterest really really
doesn't look like in the rip-off balls
or even like a like a mason jar would
have looked better one cup of cold heavy
whipping cream 2 tablespoons of sugar
honey or maple syrup so one of the three
and then a half a teaspoon of vanilla
four hot dogs yes two green onions one
jalapeno a teaspoon of chili powder a
tablespoon of vegetable oil eight flour
tortillas a cup of cheddar a cup of
Monterey Jack cheese a cup of nacho
cheese and it and just says one sour
cream tacos you're making hotdog tacos
they're not doc goes but they're very
close hotdogs quesadillas yeah their
case of dog oh my god Jason WY a dog
that looks good yeah it does kind of
look good that's like a dog go but
better yeah cuz that you like you put
the hot dog in and you melt the cheese
like you put it in cheese and roll it up
so that it melts like that's [ __ ] hype
I like
you could make a vegan version of that
yeah that sounds dogus I like the name
more than anything honestly like shouts
out to that name mm-hmm case of dog us
you ready for this one hmm
I'm proud of you for getting that one I
mean I pretty much got right okay
fair enough okay you ready here this
feel like this one you'll like this one
okay this one will make you actually
hungry four ounces of extra sharp
cheddar cheese two ounces of cream
cheese 1/4 teaspoon of sugar mustard
powder garlic powder onion powder corn
starch ground turmeric and a half a cup
of whole or reduced fat milk by the way
it's turmeric turmeric why do people say
tumeric sorry so it's cheese in what
else cheese cream cheese sugar mustard
powder garlic powder onion powder that
starts ground turmeric
Yury human is a turmeric now cheese dip
no but close well in a way is it fondue
mmm there's a specific name for it
uh-huh
I'll give you a hint yeah when you reach
for a tissue what do you call it
Kleenex there you go there's your hint
so it's named after a brand of something
I'll be death no I don't know doesn't
always come in a traditional canister
container easy cheese what's a car easy
cheesy DPP pretty busy you're not even
speaking English anymore means I'm in
the biz cheese pizza bit
correct what is it Cheez Whiz come on
saying every Z word I knew geez whiz say
cheese cheese you got one from your side
I adore this game this is fun as hell
and take it to the bank dude okay a
pound of lean ground beef two
tablespoons of butter one small yellow
onion diced one small green pepper diced
eight ounces of brown mushrooms minced
two tablespoons of ketchup one
tablespoon of Worcestershire sauce half
a teaspoon of kosher salt half a
teaspoon of fresh ground black pepper 1
tablespoon cornstarch one cup of beef
broth 8 ounces of provolone cheese
slices chopped six brioche hamburger
buns you're making burgers meatballs I
mean it's the type of burger sure baby
maybe sloppy joe you're not wrong but
it's not a traditional sloppy joe is it
does it doesn't end up in a patty form
mm-hmm no okay so it's a square patty
then so it's a Wendy's Burger mm-hmm so
it's the square patty it's absolutely
not a patty a sloppy joe isn't a patty I
know but you said it's not a sloppy joe
it is a sloppy joe it's a type of sloppy
joe but not a soppy joe because it's not
just like meat and tomato base oh so
what's the name of it that's what you're
trying to get okay okay it's ground beef
provolone cheese onions and peppers
cheesy
sloppy joe grilled cheese with sloppy
joe ground beef grilled
gbgt want me to tell you one more hint
give me another hit what is it round
with what is it rhyme with okay where's
the first letter of the name what is the
country of origin give me the hit good
hit
no okay it's a Philly cheesesteak sloppy
joe Philly cheese ok Philly Philly
cheesesteak sloppy joe mm-hmm I don't
really know why that's any different
than just like a Philly cheesesteak by
the way if you ever here's yellow Philly
cheesesteak the reason we do that is
because during twitchcon will Jason and
Lexi were meeting us at a bar and they
got in a lift and the woman who was
driving the lift was like where y'all
from and Jason was like Philly and then
she just heard going okay all right I
mean I didn't know a Philly cheesesteak
sloppy joe but to be fair I did fortune
cookie so I kind of deserved that one I
wish okay you ready it's so freakin
owned right now on me two to three
cloves of garlic depending on preference
some of you might prefer to cloves
whereas others of you might prefer three
cloves that's it that something's been
one large eggplant [ __ ] or EP is that
like on two teaspoons of olive oil two
tablespoons of tahini juice of a half
eleven half a teaspoon of salt half a
teaspoon of paprika preferably smoked
paprika are you making eggplant hummus
no are you making a roasted eggplant no
what's the beginning it's an eggplant
just an eggplant garlic olive oil tahini
lemon spices
you're just making eggplant nope I don't
even I don't think I've ever had this in
my life
roasted eggplant no mm-hmm no no that's
wrong that's incorrect as I'm telling
you it's just a roasted eggplant
do I'm gonna tell you what it rhymes
with sure Papa ghanoush baba ghanoush
there you go oh wait I thought Papa
ghanoush rhymed with baba ghanoush well
I don't think I've ever had that either
I've never had baba ghanoush how many
more sad news I do one more I got one
more for you okay gimme
gimme-gimme-gimme
an 8 ounce box of elbow macaroni freshly
cooked and drained half a pound of hot
dogs slice into round scar big plate two
and a half cups of American cheese or
two and a quarter cups of Velveeta
cheese mmm five tablespoons of unsalted
butter a small onion very finely chopped
1/4 cup of all-purpose flour 2 cups milk
1/4 teaspoon of ground black pepper and
1/2 a teaspoon of salt you're making hot
dog mac and cheese pretty close but the
pastas already cooked hot oh my god
pasta salad with hot dog pretty close is
the hot casserole I just threw together
[ __ ] kitchen ooh it's hot dogs and
husband beads this is a custom we're
gonna take a trip south of the border
for this 103 cups of rice flour yep okay
one cup of sweet
red bean paste mm-hmm one the third cup
of boiling water wait what was the first
ingredient rice flour okay sweet bean
paste boiling water 3/4 a cup of brown
sugar 1/2 a cup of untoasted sesame
seeds 6 cups of peanut oil
this is pad thai how the [ __ ] would you
make pad thai with that are you gonna
bread something I didn't say noodles I
didn't say tofu I didn't say okay so
it's flour bean paste what else
flour water sugar bean paste rice flour
sesame seeds peanut oil and it's brown
sugar pretty sure you've never eaten
this you could throw it I can throw it
can throw it I don't know sesame ball
fried sesame balls hmm never had one
could you or couldn't you throw that
yeah you could throw anything if you
throw it I'm learning so much okay ready
mm-hmm hit me someone that loves this
whole wheat flour three cups of whole
wheat flour one cup one and a half cup
of oat flour ground cinnamon mm-hmm like
that shouldn't be in here
large apple egg water coconut oil we
have made this recently whole wheat
flour flour and oat as well remember the
oat flour yeah we made it for a video
recently it's not Apple Kris
that's nasty whole wheat flour oat flour
cinnamon egg water coconut oil is it a
cannoli no well then what have we made
for our video recently coconut oil I
don't know is it a dog dog cookie
[Music]
cookies just being so cute today like I
can't stand him nasty like that doesn't
sound good at all no it's not good all
right last one
okay ten ounces of rice noodles okay
it's patch doesn't payment I was doing
it from memory yeah I know you weren't
reading anything that's how I know it's
Pad Thai sesame really we're gonna end
on that vegetable oil Sichuan
peppercorns extra firm tofu pressed and
or dried chopped into small cubes bok
choy green onions peanut butter soy
sauce lime juice red chili peppers other
stuff but that's pretty much it we have
to end on that Oh fine I'll file if I'll
find something I'll find something good
okay one on something good I wish I
could have ended on the ham and bananas
hollandaise oranges that's all the
ingredients you're making oranges no
orange juice this is a picture of a long
ass blog in front of it too yeah all
right I got a real one for you I don't
think I've ever eaten these but I've
always wanted to try one a cup of
all-purpose flour two tablespoons of
vegetable oil 2 large potatoes boiled 1
onion chopped 2 green chilies very
finely chopped 3 tablespoons of oil this
was like sessioned off so that that's
why I said oil twice half a teaspoon of
ginger half a teaspoon of garlic
coriander seed cilantro lemon and the
juice of the lemon teaspoon of turmeric
tease
garam masala and he's been a red chili
powder mmm so you're making some type of
potato well so far
mmm right it sounds like a spicy latke
no no horrible guess what is it garam
masala no look what type of food uses
that spice tasty stuff all kinds of
stuff is a like a curry potato no it's
not great potato there's no curry in it
let me tell you it sounds similar to
Jamaican germ or some more samosas
samosas mmm you know what they are no
I've only ever had the ones that you buy
frozen and then I eat them so you do
know what they're they're like a little
breaded yeah snack really good and
they're like fried I think yeah yeah
I've never som Simoes some I'm down for
some samosas some some Moses you want to
have samosas with a mimosa can I have
some of your Moses please ow my head can
I can I have some Moses have some Oh
have some Moses stop what oh your rice
and make it grow out of it okay babe
babe it's cheetah can we please have
some gruel well it's okay I I know that
and I'm fine with it honestly I don't
care
I like gruel so I like I put girl on
everything
I just keep above that Oh would you
break up with me if I had to keep a vat
of gruel always on the boiler I would
just think it's party party you being
real nasty
if Kermit was a human he would make
himself cruel
standing over ask rule 24 hours a day
stirring it nothing nasty well hopefully
you guys enjoyed this and/or played
along
I wasn't gave my life that game I'm the
self-proclaimed winner no you're not
fair enough
even when you can't win but no I'm glad
you like the idea I think I think it's
good that you don't like read the I
thought you would have to read the
recipe learn on apps but that would give
it away I think we can also do this
again and I will absolutely bring that
heat once more I hope you guys have a
wonderful week we'll see you next week
for another podcast thanks for listening
us guest recipes and remember alright
bye I finished it I finished it No thank
you guys for
[Music]
[Music]